in our morning rounds we are focusing
upon a tiny skin sensor that may
revolutionize health care skin like
silicon patches are being tested to
monitor stroke recovery and breathing
disorders a new study in the journal
science shows how they could also help
babies who are born prematurely
researchers found wireless sensors
attached to the chest and foot prove
just as reliable as traditional
electrodes for tracking baby's heart and
respiration rates temperature blood
oxygen levels and blood pressure dr. Jon
LaPook got a close look at this new
technology John good morning morning
John each year 300,000 American newborns
are admitted to the neonatal ICU the
NICU at any moment an alarm a signal
that they need help the new ultra-thin
electronic patches could break preemies
free of the wires that monitor them and
safely allow them a less confined start
to life when Olivia McDonough arrived 15
days ahead of schedule she needed
surgery to help her breathe and swallow
her first two weeks were spent wired to
machines at Chicago's lurie Children's
Hospital watched closely by her mom
Casey it's just a constant reminder that
we're here and that she's maybe not yet
a normal newborn baby all these wires
monitor and newborns breathing and
circulation and alert doctors - any sign
of infection when you're breastfeeding
is it a little bit clunky we're kind of
at the mercy of the cords now a
collaboration between doctors and
engineers at Northwestern University has
given birth to these skin-like wireless
sensors fine metal threads capture
information like vital signs and oxygen
levels an antenna under the crib powers
the sensors and streams data to a
monitoring station I'm personally very
excited about the possibility of using
engineering to improve human health for
more than a decade John Rogers and his
research team have been fine-tuning this
sensor technology even though this looks
like we might be in an icy
we're in your lab so you're able to
figure out all the ins and outs yeah
it's really important to think about the
full picture we had a clear vision this
is where we wanted to end up we couldn't
be happier with the outcome the sensors
are gentle on fragile neonatal skin
which is 40 to 60 percent thinner than
that of an adult study co-author dr. Amy
pallor treats skin injuries in preemies
45 percent of them come away with some
kind of scars from procedures and from
the adhesives that attach them to these
various wired devices those wireless
patches allow parents to do something
they're wired to do cuddle with their
newborns there have been studies that
have shown that that skin-to-skin
contact especially in these premature
babies decreases the risk of development
of infection of kidney issues of lung
issues it goes a long way and cutting
those cords would have one very
practical advantage changing a diaper
will be easier without all the chords
while final testing is completed babies
in the study wore both the new patches
and the old wires as a backup doctors
say it will be about two years before
these sensors are in regular use and I
got to tell you I know just how great it
would be to have them because my son
Noah was born at 31 weeks three pounds
six who's in the neonatal ICU for about
three weeks and but it ended very well
because he's an active college graduate
and now I can finally hug them whenever
I want yeah okay with John how much it's
gonna cost when when they roll out
relatively cheap ten bucks each and so
it's gonna make it a big difference you
have right there no where's that sounds
like a good deal Jon LaPook doc oh it's
great to see you nice to see you